today on the matt well show the governor
of texas has provoked extreme outrage
from the left by declaring that all
so-called gender affirming medical care
of minors in the state now qualifies and
will be prosecuted as child abuse he's
facing backlash and mutiny over this but
he's obviously completely correct we'll
talk about why also the latest on the
crisis in ukraine and the incompetent
response from the baby administration
speaking of which john kerry has come
out to explain that global war is bad
mainly because of all the carbon
emissions plus biden announces his
supreme court pick lots of news today in
our daily cancellation the celebs are
chiming in on the ukraine situation and
their contributions to the conversation
have so far been far worse than you can
imagine i'll play something for you
today that is so cringy and embarrassing
that it probably needs some kind of
surgeon general warning attached to it
all of that and more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know 40 years ago ronald reagan saw
massive inflation unlike anything the
country had ever seen before until today
in reagan's own words inflation is as
violent as a mugger as frightening as an
armed robber and as deadly as a hitman
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration if
you've not yet called birchgold the only
people i trust to help you diversify
your 401ks and iras into gold then
you're missing the boat actually you're
treading the treading water without a
life vest birch gold has your life vest
let them help you convert an ira or 401k
into a tax sheltered ira in gold with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
eight-plus rating with the better
business bureau you can trust birch gold
to protect your savings and uh all you
gotta do is text walsh to 98 98 98 to
get a free info get on gold reagan you
the biggest threat to your wealth and uh
you can protect your wealth and protect
yourself now and you could do it with
birch gold it's very easy all you have
to do
to make that happen is text walsh to 98
98 98 against walsh to 98 98 98 to get
your free info kit now
we will have the latest on the ukraine
situation at the top of the five
headlines but while important events
unfold overseas there are things
happening closer to home which still
deserve our attention one of the
consequences of living in a society
effectively run by social media and
cable news is that it can be hard to
properly prioritize things or to know
where we should focus our attention at
any given time because lots of things
tend to get lost in the shuffle even
things that are that are happening right
in front of you can get lost you know
binoculars are good because they help
you see things that are happening far
away it can often be useful to know
what's over the horizon but if you walk
around with binoculars on every day all
day
it's going to wreak havoc on your depth
perception and soon you'll be not able
to distinguish far from near and lots of
things closest to you will escape your
site completely and i think thanks to
modern media we're all basically walking
around with binoculars on all the time
except in this case the binoculars
themselves are unreliable you can never
be sure if the images you're seeing or
distorted or not maybe a fun house
mirror would be a better analogy but in
any case all of that to say i want to
begin with a significant series of
events unfolding here in the united
states though you may or may not have
heard about it
in texas this week governor abbott
announced that so-called gender
affirming care for minors would be
treated and prosecuted as child abuse in
the state
here's a national review with the report
on this says governor greg abbott on
tuesday ordered the texas department of
family protective services to
investigate doctors and parents who
enable a child's gender transition
surgery abbott's direction comes after
dfps confirmed in august that gender
transition surgery on children
constitutes child abuse when abbott asks
the department to issue a determination
on the matter texas attorney general ken
paxton also said earlier this week that
gender transition procedures including
hormone therapy puberty blockers and sex
reassignment procedures are abuse under
existing law abbott wrote in a letter to
dfps on tuesday directing dfps to quote
conduct a prompt and thorough
investigation of any reported instances
of these abusive procedures in the state
of texas the governor writes that the
attorney general's opinion makes clear
it is already against the law to subject
texas children to a wide variety of
elected procedures for gender transition
including reassignment surgery that can
cause sterilization mastectomies
removals of removal of otherwise healthy
body parts and administration of puberty
blocking drugs or supraphysiologic doses
of testosterone or estrogen the letter
was also sent to other texas agencies
including the texas health and human
services commission the texas medical
board and the texas education agency
so this was at texas actually i believe
last year they tried to pass a law uh
banning these procedures
and it didn't make it through
and so now greg abbott is saying you
know what it's already banned because uh
child abuse is banned in this state and
this is child abuse
now
we'll talk about why this move was
entirely justified and necessary in a
moment but first i think we have to tell
the rest of the story
because as you would expect the backlash
against this move by the texas governor
has been severe
five leftist da's in texas have already
announced that they're not gonna follow
the order they're going to defy the
governor's order and refuse to prosecute
this kind of child abuse because they're
big fans of child abuse and i'm
paraphrasing what they said but this is
basically what they said that they're
big fans of child abuse and they want to
see more of it they're not going to
prosecute it
i mean they want to see more kids uh
with you know their body parts chopped
off that's the they're into it they like
it
and so
this sort of mutiny is happening in
texas and this comes after several days
of hysterical outrage from the left in
the trans lobby celebrities like jamie
lee curtis and busy phillips both of
whom have trans or non-binary
quote-unquote children have spoken out
so is the actress formerly known as
ellen page gabriel gabrielle union also
the parent of a quote trans kid called
the policy dangerous and horrific
josh gad who's the guy who voices the
snowman and frozen said it's pure evil
the media has published articles you
know with dramatic headlines claiming
that texas is quote denying health care
to trans youth and sometimes the
headlines are even less subtle like this
one in the nation that says texas is
terrorizing trans youth
and of course as expected there have
been the emotional interviews with some
of the parents who are now rightly
categorized as abusers by abbott's new
policy here's just one example
they are parents of a child who is
transgender and you may remember in 2016
when they invited attorney general ken
paxton over for dinner to discuss trans
rights well fast forward six years for
him
to call us the child abusers is
such a betrayal earlier this week
governor greg abbott and the attorney
general wrote to state departments
calling gender affirming procedures as
quote child abuse asking them to
investigate so it's not really a
question of whether it's health care
right it's a question of what authority
parents have and that parental authority
is federally protected joanna grossman
is a law professor at smu she teaches
family and gender law says the only
teeth in these directives is fear
for him to sit at our table then call us
child abusers
how about invite me over for dinner i'll
come have dinner with you
and i'll look you in your face in your
own house and call you child abusers
because that's what you are
you should be in prison
you don't deserve to have your kids
you're hurting them you're bad people
you don't love your kids
because when you love your kids you
don't do this to them you don't poison
them and mutilate them
now you notice that now suddenly the
left cares about parental rights they
believe that parents have essentially
two rights first
to kill their children in the womb and
then to have them castrated or mutilated
outside of the womb those are that's
like pretty much the entire list that
exhausts the list of parental rights as
far as they see it
better o'rourke seeking to complete the
trifecta by losing a senate race a
presidential primary race and now a
governor's race put out a video
as he's running for governor now shortly
after the the announcement making the
familiar and totally false connection
between so-called gender affirming care
and a reduction in suicide among
so-called trans youth let's watch that
youth in the education system of texas i
was wondering what you were going to do
to protect my rights and my parents
rights to be able to put me on
testosterone the trans suicide rate has
been the highest it's ever been in texas
since those bills have been placed i
mean we're seeing people trying to take
their lives right now and it's a tough
thing for us to talk about but you're
right we should say it out loud so we
speak about everyone in this state with
pride we talk about a texas that is big
enough for all of us we target no one
based on any difference between us
whether it is the color of your skin
your country of national origin or the
fact that you are non-binary i think
you're amazing i'm proud of you i want
you to do great things in this state and
i'm going to support you in doing that
and i'm going to say that publicly as
the governor of this state that's going
to be a big change for texas it just
feels like he would be defending me and
caring about my rights as a trans
non-binary person it feels like he'd
care and he'd actually listen to our
voices and our thoughts about everything
so inspiring better
now let's um
introduce some reality first of all
there is no evidence at all that sex
change procedures in children whether
drugs or surgery will prevent them from
committing suicide later in life that's
a lie
just a lie that's all it is
one of many that these people tell
they use suicide as emotional blackmail
that's how evil they are
coercing people and parents into
tolerating the mutilation of children
based on the false choice that either
children will be mutilated or they'll
kill themselves
that's that's the choice that's
presented
well
we can drug and poison and mutilate them
or they can kill themselves your choice
no that's not the choice it's not
grounded in reality
in fact available studies show that the
suicide rate among trans people remains
enormously high whether they have
surgery or not
there are no reliable studies that show
that
trans people have sky-high suicide rates
and then you get them
surgery and you put them in a really
affirming environment and then the
suicide rate goes down to you know the
the national average
no such studies exist
because it's not true
why because being at war with your
identity unable to accept yourself for
who you truly are breeds despair
and no drug or surgery can solve it
the only way to solve it is to help the
gender confused individual to see
reality and embrace it for what it is
and embrace themselves for who they are
you know and by the way
if um if we need this in order to
prevent suicide
was was there a whole 20 years ago was
there a whole rash of kids killing
themselves because um at that point none
of them were allowed to get so-called
gender affirming care
i mean you go back 20 years ago and this
basically didn't exist i mean there were
there were pretty much no kids being
subjected to this or very very few
was there was there an epidemic of
suicide for all those years
of kids who were not able to uh be
mutilated and drugged and so they killed
themselves was that happening no it
wasn't
because this again is a lie
also keep keep this in mind whenever you
hear these breezy statements about the
supposed long-term benefits of this kind
of quote medical treatment in children
remember that never before in history
have millions of children been subjected
to this treatment nobody can know the
long-term effects for sure because this
hasn't been done before
the current crop of children are lab
rats it's an enormous social and medical
experiment being conducted on an entire
generation of children so check back in
20 years to see how it turned out
so we can already make some common sense
predictions and none of them are good
here's the point well there's really two
points
one it is a simple fact
that what they're calling medical
treatment
can more accurately be described as
poisoning castration and mutilation in a
very literal and straightforward sense
when you give unnecessary hormone pills
to physically healthy minors you're
poisoning them
when you give a drug like lupron to a
pubescent boy to block puberty you are
chemically castrating him which is why
the very same drug has been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders
and when you perform a medically
unnecessary double mastectomy on a
physically healthy 14 year old girl as
is currently happening all across the
country
to 14 year olds
you are mutilating her
does it count as abuse when you drug
poison castrate and butcher children
well i'm unaware of any workable
definition of abuse that would exempt
those things
secondly
none of the children consenting to this
treatment are consenting
they can't all of our laws especially
the laws prohibiting things like child
molestation are grounded in the idea
that minors cannot fully consent even if
they say yes to something verbally that
does not qualify as full consent because
they lack the maturity and the
psychological development and the
perspective necessary to make informed
rational and healthy decisions for
themselves this is also why
when a a 14 year old commits a crime
in most cases they aren't charged as
adults
why well because we say
they did this thing it was bad but they
they didn't they couldn't have fully
chosen to do it because they didn't they
didn't fully understand what they were
doing
and yet the same people who want us to
believe
that 12 year olds
can consent to having their bodies
drugged and mutilated those same people
would say that
you know even 18 year olds shouldn't be
tried as adults because they don't know
what they're doing
i mean look make a remember the 16 year
old kids
who
who
carjacked the guy in dc and killed him
and all they cared about afterwards was
finding their phone
that's like make a venn diagram
where you know you've got the people who
supported trying those girls as children
not adults
and um also the people who think that
because they didn't know what they're
doing
and also the people who think that 10
year olds can consent to gender
affirming care
gonna be a lot of people in that middle
bubble there
a lot of overlap in those groups
which is incoherent
and because children can't choose these
treatments they also cannot choose the
consequences that will come down the
road
thousands of kids soon to be millions of
kids are undergoing medical procedures
that will make them sterile and
infertile for life
can they choose that
can a 13 year old actually choose to
never have children
what does a choice mean made by someone
that age you know when i was 20
i thought i'd never have kids i i
couldn't imagine wanting kids when i was
20
as an adult
by 25 i had two
so what about 13 i can't even remember
what i thought at 13 because it was so
long ago and i was so young that i might
as well have been a different person
kids are making lifelong decisions now
that their older selves will have to
live with forever
there's a reason why you know when you
think back to your childhood
your memories often have a kind of
dreamlike quality to them
and sometimes you might even confuse a
dream from your childhood with an actual
event
because the two are sort of stored in
your brain in the same way and
you remember them the same way they have
the same kind of texture to them and
feeling to them why is that because you
viewed the world so differently when you
were a kid you experienced it so
differently you had such a different
perspective that your memories are like
dreams
can you imagine if you were saddled with
a lifelong physical disability because
of something that you decided way back
then and can you imagine
if your parents
went along with it
how could you ever talk to your parents
again
well soon many millions of young adults
will be in exactly that spot there is a
wave of misery coming
that we cannot even comprehend
unless we stop it now
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know we live in a very exhausting
world and that's why i'm so grateful
every day
for helix sleep my helix mattress and um
it has a quiz you know that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for for
you and the way that you sleep uh that's
what the quiz is all about everybody's
unique and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix sleep mattress helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers as well
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store ever again they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free we'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will helix even has financing
options and flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never far away
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.comwalsh
that's helixsleep.com
walls for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
all right so let's uh check in with the
buying administration and their response
to the crisis in uh ukraine
um
so we got a few we'll start with we have
to john kerry with with a clip that is
like like so many others it's it's
something that you you could take this
and put it on babylon be
and you know you would you would believe
that it was parody but this is actual
real life so we'll get that to that in a
second
um well let's go through some of these
clips of joe biden addressing the nation
yesterday
and um answering questions
in a press conference a few questions
anyway
um about his response to putin and what
he's going to do about it so let's go
down the list here and start with uh
clip 5a
if sanctions cannot stop president putin
what penalty can i didn't say sanctions
couldn't stop him
you've been talking about the threat of
these sanctions for several weeks now
yes but the threat of the sanctions and
imposing the sanctions and seeing the
effect of the sanctions are two
different things
there are two different things and we're
now going to he's going to begin to see
the effect of the sanctions
and what will that do how will that
change his mindset here given he's
because he was so weak in his country
that he'll have to make a very very
difficult choices the weather to
continue to move toward being a second
rate power or in fact respond you said
in recent weeks that big nations cannot
bluff when it comes to something like
this you recently said that the idea of
personally sanctioning president putin
was on the table is that a step that
you're prepared to take and if not bluff
is on the table
sanctioning president putin yes why not
sanction him today sir mr president
why not sanction him today
so we're not gonna we're not gonna go
after putin personally we're not gonna
do anything to make him hurt personally
and you know the other the other real
big thing here is that um
we're not going to do anything about uh
oil and gas i mean we you know we still
are going to be relying on russia
for
our energy needs just like the entire
western world is
because we have no choice at this point
i mean he has us literally against a
barrel here he has us over over a barrel
uh in more ways than one
because we had the opportunity leading
up to this to make ourselves uh or at
least get closer to the objective of
energy independence
but biden put a stop to that
democrats have been have been fighting
against that
for years now
and so what do we do now
well we have these
toothless
um pointless sanctions let's go to clip
six
clearly have not been enough to deter
vladimir putin to this point what is
going to stop him how and when does this
end and do you see him trying to go
beyond ukraine and a second question
i'll just give to you now this statement
that he gave last night will that the
what the threat that he gave the west
will face consequences greater than any
you have faced in history is he
threatening a nuclear strike
i have no idea
what he's threatening i know what he has
done number one
number two no one expected the sanctions
to prevent anything from happening
it has to show this going to take time
and we have to show resolve so he knows
what's coming and so the people of
russia know what he's brought on them
that's what this is all about this is
going to take time it's not going to
occur he's going to say oh my god these
sanctions are coming i'm going to stand
down
he's going to test the resolve of the
west to see if we stay together and we
will
we will and it will impose significant
costs on him
i think the most significant thing in
that clip is uh the president united
states was asked
sir is uh
are we gonna be nuked
and his answer was well i have no idea
maybe
stay tuned and find out
you could not possibly select someone
who's
less equipped to handle a moment like
this
than joe biden
i mean that that alone should be and
there's just so many things happening
but but that alone it should is major
headline news
the president united states could not
offer any assurance that we won't get
nuked
because he also has no idea what what
he's saying
and you can you can tell based on the
words he's using you can also just see
it in his eyes that he always looks
lost
and that's why i always say that i
prefer if he doesn't i know
he he often gets criticized because he
doesn't appear before the media enough
um
he takes too long to get out and and
and address situations like this
when the invasion was first underway
you know donald trump was was speaking
about and he was on top of it but biden
was asleep
biden said i'll get to it in the morning
and what you hear oftentimes from the
right and even on the left is the
criticism that he needs we need to see
more of him i disagree completely
i think the more time he spends on tv
on camera the worse it is for
everybody because you could just tell
that he is this bumbling confused
totally lost
daughtering old man
it doesn't doesn't help at all in in any
way to have that image projected
i would prefer if he just doesn't appear
on camera again
um
okay let's go to this so john kerry is
uh what is his official title he's i
think the the climate
ambassador so he's also a daughtering
old confused man um
and he he could just go off and retire
and and be done
but he doesn't want to do that he has to
hang on to some semblance of power he
tried to be president that didn't work
out uh he was in the senate for a long
time and so he just
give him give him some kind of title
give him something to do he needs to
feel important so they made him
climate ambassador and um here he is
speaking to the media
and this was before the invasion
actually happened but here's here's his
primary concern let's listen to this
i'm very concerned about
i'm concerned about ukraine because of
the people of ukraine and because of the
principles that are at risk
in terms of international law
and trying to change boundaries of
international law by force
i thought we lived in a world that had
said no to that kind of activity and i
hope diplomacy will win but massive
uh emissions consequences to the war but
equally importantly you're going to lose
people's focus you're going to lose
certainly big country attention because
they will be diverted and and i think it
could have a damaging impact so you know
i think hopefully president putin would
realize
that in the northern part of his country
they used to live on 66 of a nation that
was over frozen land
now it's thawing
and his infrastructure is at risk
and the people of russia at risk and so
i hope president putin will help us to
stay on track with respect to what we
need to do for the climate
well that'll do it
just just tell putin that uh it's
hurting the environment and i'm sure
that'll convince him
so as far as john kerry is concerned the
prospect of a major war of even world
war
it's uh bad for two reasons and one is
that think of all the emissions
that are going to be spewed into the air
and uh but then also look let's let's
not make straw man of his argument
that's not the only thing the only
problem with with a world war
the second and he says equally as
important is that it will distract
people's focus
from the problem of emissions and
climate change
we uh we have very unserious people
running the government
we have become a very unserious
nation and civilization
which makes us again
uh woefully unequipped
for serious moments like this and
speaking of being unserious um here's
another another example not just in the
government but also in media so the view
you know if you tune into the view
whoever makes the mistake of doing that
um maybe
i don't know i don't know what you're
expecting when it comes to something
like this i don't know if you're
expecting
in real insight into uh into geopolitics
from the ladies of the view but if
that's what you're looking for you're
gonna be disappointed um here is joy
behar what's what's her main you know
concern what is she worried might happen
if this um if this conflict spreads and
becomes a world war yeah there's global
warming but as far as she's concerned
there's um
a consequence even more dire than that
listen
estimates are 50 000 ukrainians will be
dead or wounded and that this is going
to start a humanitarian crisis a refugee
crisis in europe we're talking about
five million people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
and now this
first there was a pandemic of 5 million
people died and it stopped me from
taking it my italy vacation that i've
wanted to take it's been my dream
and now we have war
what else what else is going to happen
to me is joy behar so i think some some
very compelling arguments have been
presented to putin
and hopefully he's paying attention
because
listen you got to stop this
because if you don't
it's going to kill more polar bears from
global warming
and if that's not enough to persuade you
mr president
then also you're preventing joy behar
from going on an italian vacation that
by the way she's wanted to take for four
years
we'll have to see
we'll have to see if that if that does
the trick
um okay let's um
let's go this is hot off the presses
here president buzz from fox president
biden is nominating judge cantanji brown
jackson to the supreme court making good
on a campaign promise to pick the first
black woman for the nation's highest
court uh brown jackson 51 is a judge for
the u.s court of appeals for the
district of columbia biden will make the
announcement on friday brown jackson has
faced heightened scrutiny over a
judicial record that includes high
profile rulings later overruled by
higher judges
beyond that uh
i'm just seeing this news now so i don't
know anything else about her is she a
crazy far left uh wacko
you can assume because
a democrat wouldn't nominate anybody
else
um
but one thing that that i'm hearing
really from actually from both sides and
even some republicans have come out
already and said that well she's
she's uh she's very qualified for the
job
and that's what we're hearing from the
media she's a
super qualified
nominee
uh if you look at her record you look at
all of her experience very very
qualified for the job
and she might be
she might be very qualified
um like i said i haven't looked at her
resume i don't know
but this is exactly the problem
if you this was exactly the problem with
coming out ahead of time and saying i'm
going to find a black woman
we're going to narrow it down to begin
with
to only black women and i'm not going to
consider anybody outside of that
and no matter how qualified they are
well
when you eventually nominate a black
woman even if she is the most qualified
candidate
of all potential candidates of all races
you've already undermined those
qualifications and undermine your own
pick
by announcing ahead of time this is
going to be an affirmative action thing
and you're only looking at people from a
certain race and gender
category and that becomes even dumber to
announce ahead of time i'm going to pick
a black woman
was already a dumb move it's even dumber
if you do end up picking someone who
legitimately is the most qualified out
of any potential candidate
so if you were going to do that then why
not just
nominate her
without saying anything ahead of time
making any promises that it's going to
be a black woman just nominate her
and then people say oh you nominated a
black woman
and then you can easily say that well i
know i'm here because she's the most
qualified
you can't really make that argument now
because again you said ahead of time
that the vast majority of the potential
applicants are going to be ruled out
from the start
because of their race or gender
all right let's um
i've had this also had this case that
i've had here on the docket to talk
about and let's get to it now um reading
now from new york post this is from a
couple days ago
and this is the language they use in
their article okay it's not my language
the transgender woman convicted of
sexually assaulting a ten-year-old girl
reportedly boasted about her two-year
sentence as los angeles's progressive
district attorney
admitted the punishment may have been
too lenient
district attorney george gascon who
faces on ongoing recall efforts said
sunday that he would have handled hannah
tubbs's case differently had he known
about her disregard for the harm that
she caused her 10 year old victim
the prosecutor said a statement while
for most people several years of jail
time is adequate it may not be for miss
tubbs after her sentencing in our case i
became aware of extremely troubling
statements she made about her case the
resolution of it and the young girl that
she harmed
while in custody tubbs
made crude and disparaging comments
about the girl that he had victimized
while boasting that um she
so again going back to the language in
article wouldn't have to register as a
sex offender um citing a recorded call
to her father so we have some of that
audio we can play this is from a fox 11
report this is
so-called hannah tubbs and if you're
watching this on video you can see the
photograph
of miss hannah tubbs
which is just it's a dude okay this is a
guy
actually
not even making any effort at all to
even look like a woman just a guy with a
with like kind of a
a gross um half beard and just a guy
like a buzz cut
but he said oh you know what actually
i'm a woman and so he's going to get to
go you know he if he went to prison he'd
be going to a woman's prison except in
this case he's not going to prison
because they decided to try him as a
minor here's some of the recording of
hannah tubbs talking i believe he's
talking to his father in jail and this
is some of what came out uh let's listen
to that
don't worry about it it's a strike but
they're going to plea i'm going to plead
out to him and plead guilty they're
going to be on probation and it's going
to be dropped it's going to be done done
i won't have to register once or nothing
for an offender you don't have to
register i won't have to do none of that
so what are they going to do to you that
nothing gascone now admits the tub
sentence not tough enough saying in a
statement if we knew about her disregard
for the harm she caused we would have
handled this case differently the
complex issues and facts of her
particular case were unusual and i
should have treated them that way
so this again is someone
now 26 years old
who had a few years ago molested a
ten-year-old girl
and was sentenced to um two years in a
juvenile facility
not tried as an adult
and
also will not will not have to register
a sex offender as you heard him bragging
about he's very excited about it
not gonna have to register as a sex
offender
so we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
let him out
release him on to the public
and we're not going to tell anybody
we're not going to
alert alert the communities
about who this guy is and what he's done
so hey i mean your kids might um go over
there and knock on his door for
trick-or-treating
you would you would be none the wiser
now again the prosecutor says that he
wasn't aware of these calls and there
was there's much more that um quote
unquote hannah tubbs said in these calls
gloating about the fact about what he
did and and um disparaging his victim
and
gloating about the lenient sentence
although it shouldn't that shouldn't
even matter
right the fact that he made these calls
and was bragging about the fact that he
uh doesn't have to go to prison
that shouldn't that shouldn't matter
you shouldn't need the calls to know
that this perverted freak needs to be
behind bars for a long time i mean
really forever
it really it actually shouldn't make a
difference
that he was bragging about it in phone
calls
but actually as it turns out
the d.a did know about this so this is
from fox
says files obtained by fox news digital
show los angeles ditch attorney george
gascon's office was aware of disturbing
jailhouse recordings of transgender
child molester hannah tubbs gloating
about a light sentence on february 2nd
gascone released a statement sunday
denying knowledge of the recordings
until after tubbs of sentencing but
audio files sent to gascon's office on
february 2nd contained titles such as
pled to avoid adult
jail time racist
time in the hole doesn't care because
he's been sentenced won't have to
register
and then in other
other titles as well some of them more
more vulgar
so we have evidence that the d.a was
given these uh
these files and knew about it
and uh still can't pass down the
sentence anyway
and as bad as all that is
just adding insult to injury here
reading these media reports
even from supposedly conservative
outlets
media reports that take a negative view
of what's happened and rightly so
they still
are
diligently making sure that they respect
the pronouns
of this child rapist
still and you saw what the guy looked
like
this dude who is just a dude
just a just a just a guy
who who just declared one day actually
i'm a woman
and even with him
they feel that they have to respect his
pronouns
and refer to him as a woman
why
because you know it's not true
and are we worried about this
affirming this man's self-perception
are you actually worried about hurting
his feelings
that's just the
the total absurdity of it
even the people who are outraged by it
and rightly so
still are not so outraged that they
would dare hurt this man's feelings by
misgendering him
that's what we've gotten okay let's get
now to the comment section do you know
their name
well if you want to leave a video
comment go to dailywire.com
sweetbabycomments and uh it says on my
clip sheet here
that we've got a funny
this is a in all caps supposedly a funny
comment
that's what mckenna producer mckenna is
claiming anyway so we'll see
you're on the hook let's see let's watch
hey mr mayor walls how's it going i i'm
sorry buddy i just can't bring myself to
call nobody sweet baby daddy you know at
least not at this junk [ __ ] you know but
uh but it's uncle barbara here and i saw
that one video that you had and a guy
returning the shopping carts you know
the uh don't make me maddy sweet baby
daddy
right and it's all good and everything
but uh but i got that how about
something else how about i submit this
to you how about return your bottles huh
how about we do that
return your bottles and then you hit the
little button and go poop and then look
at that you got a little something for
your effort you know every little bit
helps you see and then how about this
return your library books you lazy
schmuck some of us are waiting to read
them books you got checked out you know
return your library books or die oh then
maybe this one throw away your stupid
mass and return to normal huh how about
that kind of return huh return to
normalcy
oh but i i got the best one though i get
the best one right here you know how
about you know return to jesus huh how
about we all do that that'll that'll
take care of the whole mess because uh
you know whether you return to jesus
you're not he's coming back and if you
have him return to jesus if you haven't
come to him then the whole thing's gonna
go south real quick you want to go to a
g double hockey sticks no will that
worship jesus your mu run
but until then i'll keep returning the
shopping carts
shook pocket maddie sweet baby daddy
uh mckenna's banned from the show
that this is how long was that seven and
a half minutes
what happened what was that
why was that
who goes to libraries i have a lot of
questions
and i'm glad that we could all
experience that together um
and uh
mckenna zip recruiter is where i would
go to find a new job
so cool papa j magic says this wouldn't
have happened under trump uh talking
about ukraine now well this that video
might not have happened under trump
either this would have happened under
trump you can hate them all you want but
it's true uh i we know that it wouldn't
have happened we don't have to we don't
have to speak hypothetically about it it
didn't happen under trump
there was four years of
relative peace about as peaceful as the
world can possibly be
um under trump we can you could
speculate about why that is and how it
turned out that way but it did not
happen under trump
and i think
one of the reasons for that is um
that trump
was not very predictable
and so i think the world leaders
especially in places like china and
russia
you know they didn't know exactly what
he would do how he responded to things
and there are there are downsides to a
lack of predictability
in your president but this is one of the
upsides now
biden on the other hand is very
predictable i mean he's a vegetable and
you know exactly what he's going to do
which is you know basically nothing
um
buckman says i agree with matt's view on
the u.s convoy i fear that it's far too
disorganized to actually achieve
anything
yeah i found out after the fact a couple
people messaged me and and said that uh
i played the clip of the one of the guys
in dc who says that he's an organizer of
the
of the truck convoy at least according
to the comments i've gotten they said
that he's this guy's not even a trucker
i don't know if that's true or not
exactly but
um
it is it'll be kind of interesting if
you have non-truckers that are now
involved in organizing this truck convoy
um
yeah i think
if you're if you're going to do
something like this
at a minimum
you have to have very clear goals in
mind like we talked about yesterday you
have to know exactly why you're doing it
and have a unified message
the problem one of the many problems
with this convoy is depending on who
you're listening to
and who's doing the interview you kind
of get different reasons different
motivations behind it
and that's not going to be nearly good
enough because if you start causing
gridlock and shutting down cities and
doing all that kind of stuff
people are going to want to know why
you're doing it
and if the answer is sort of a shrug
well you know just in general freedom
that's not going to be good enough
answer
all right um
bro total says matt not doing dog chores
because the dog trainer told natsu is
simply him doing what we've all been
told to do for the last two years he's
just listening to the experts
his wife is a dog science denier thank
you that's exactly the point that i've
been big mike says matt with all your
criticisms of the military why don't you
join and show us how it's done
well first of all my criticisms are of
the the leadership especially civilian
leadership
not of the individuals who are choosing
to serve
i think that's a pretty obvious
distinction there
and
a nuance that i believe you're choosing
not to see
second no i don't want to go fight
potentially a world war i mean i'm
against that
i don't want any of our people fighting
that
um i have no interest in potentially
dying to fight russia over ukraine
or even to protect a europe that
europeans lack the will to defend
themselves
i don't want that for me why would i why
would i sign up to potentially do that i
don't want it for anybody
that's my whole point
my point is i don't want our
service members
being thrown into the middle of a
conflict like this
where many of them will die
and so i don't understand the response
from you and so many others saying well
you you have no right to say that if you
haven't served
i think that's a more logical response
for the people who haven't served or are
not serving now and yet are just
casually saying yeah let's let's go to
war with russia
when you're kind of
casually trying to
inject our troops into the middle of
something and waving away the fact that
uh many of them are going to die and you
you are not serving yourself while
you're doing that i think that's a
relevant criticism
and in terms of the criticisms over the
the
continued wokeness of the military
um again no i i wouldn't want to join
you know an increasingly welcomed
military i'm
i'm i'm not going to want my sons to
join the military either if things
continue this way
and that's something that at a certain
point in my life i couldn't imagine
myself saying but now that's how i feel
about it if things continue down this
road
where radical leftism continues to
infiltrate into the military
because if my sons go serve you know the
thing is when you're in the military you
can't just get up and leave one day
you are totally subjected to it
but again that's not a criticism of the
military itself or the people who join
it's a criticism of how it's run
that's a distinction as we see conflict
unfolding between russia and ukraine
it's become increasingly clear that
dictators are not to be trusted and as
our country supported ukraine's move to
hand over its nuke in nukes in 1994 in
exchange for russia's promise to not
invade it appears that we are not to be
trusted either that's why it's more
important than ever to understand just
how insidious these foreign threats are
within our own country and we have to we
have just the way to do that and help
you do that it's our new show the enemy
within it's a docu-series featuring
acclaimed journalist an expert in
national threats lee smith smith
uncovers a political coup orchestrated
by america's ruling class to generate
their own wealth and power in exchange
for the slow rise of china's
communist party in america in the uh the
fourth episode lee describes how the nba
has come to depend on china for much of
its profits and as a result how the nba
and its players have become a mouthpiece
for ccp propaganda check out the trailer
here
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within because you're trying
to obscure responsibility for four
million people dying around the world
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness that matched the cruelty
and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class throughout
the political corporate academic
cultural and media establishment my name
is lee smith i've been a journalist for
more than 30 years this is the most
astonishing espionage and infiltration
operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
all episodes of the enemy within are
streaming now exclusively at the daily
wire so if you're not a member now's the
time to change that head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
you know also there's no better place
for a grand meeting of the minds than
sitting down over a cup of coffee and
letting conversation flow nobody knows
that better than ben shapiro in his new
show the search will be taking you to
his favorite local spots to let you in
on a secret which is where the
conversation goes when the camera isn't
rolling
you know the camera is rolling but you
know whatever the second episode of the
search features his very good friend
highly lauded historian niel ferguson
it's an excellent conversation and i
highly recommend you check it out the
episode released last night and it's
exclusive to daily wire members so if
you're not currently a member head to
dailywire.com subscribe
to join today
and finally you know it's it's always
time for new voices to enter the
transgender conversation because as
always diversity is extremely important
that's why i authored the best-selling
children's lgbtq plus book johnny the
walrus and also i was invited to dr phil
to discuss these issues as an expert in
the field with other people who were
supposedly experts but they couldn't
tell me what a woman was so it turns out
that they were not experts and if you
haven't seen any of those clips go check
it out but even more importantly if you
haven't picked up a copy of my
bestselling children's book you should
do so immediately it sold out of 48
hours when it was released
literary sensation of the year but don't
worry more copies are on the way reserve
johnny the walrus now on amazon or go to
johnnywalrus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
ever since the current crisis began in
ukraine the world has shuttered and
dread in anticipation terrified that at
any moment the celebs might get involved
and we all knew that it was bound to
happen
and it only took a few weeks of the
pandemic before charlize theron and her
celebrity friends recorded a video of
themselves singing imagine a rendition
so horrible you'll remember so off-key
and tone-deaf in every sense of the term
that it somehow managed to be even worse
than the original version
so what would the celebs do
about ukraine that was the question what
song would they sing what psa would they
record
these are the questions that plagued us
and now they've been answered and i'm
afraid that it's it's it's far worse
than you could have ever imagined anna
lynn mccord is an actress that i've
never heard of but she's apparently
appeared in many films
her wikipedia informs me that she is
also she was also a teen choice award
nominee in 2009 so her resume is
undoubtedly impressive but it can do
nothing to rescue what i'm about to play
for you miss mccord
has apparently been watching the events
unfold across the ocean and has arrived
at the conclusion that whatever the
particulars of this geopolitical
conflict really it's all about her
she may not be a foreign policy expert
mind you
but she does know based on her
experience
that she is somehow at the center of it
just as she may not be an astronomer by
trade but she still knows that the earth
and the sun and all of the stars revolve
around her
inaudible theory of the universe you
might say and that's what led her to
record and publish this video your
challenge here will be to listen to it
for more than five seconds
without dying of cringe in fact
in penance for all of our sins i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to let this play
for 80 seconds
and don't look away don't cover your
ears
don't turn off this off
we're going to endure this together
and and be better for it in our
suffering
watch
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul-stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you lived in a cruel unjust world
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
i can't do it anymore i don't know we
didn't get 80 seconds in i just i can't
um
some breaking news for you putin has
heard this poem and is now launching a
full-scale nuclear attack against the
united states because of it and you can
hardly blame him i actually welcome it
now there are times in life
when you encounter something so crazy so
deranged that your mind kind of shuts
down and prevents you from confronting
and comprehending
the insanity in its fullness and a
sentence like
i'm so sorry i was not your mother
has just that effect it's the kind of
thought that only a lunatic could have
in a situation like this much less say
out loud on video
it's therefore not really possible for a
rational person
to understand the thought process that
went into this i mean did she actually
imagine a possible scenario where putin
would be scrolling twitter
stumble across her poem
listen to it and be like swayed by it
did she imagine putin tears welling up
in his eyes calling his generals and
saying never mind the war's off
i choose laughter and joy instead
come let us all class pans and
sing songs of love and hope
is that what she thought would happen
perhaps
though it's more likely that she simply
intended to get a bunch of likes and
retweets and pats on the back
from an adoring public which was also a
delusional hope
she probably hadn't thought it through
much more than that
also i can't help but note the fact that
anna
from what i can tell based on her
available biography um is not a mother
so she is a childless 35 year old woman
and yet she's quite sure that her
parenting skills if only she had
children would be so flawless that she
could as she says in her poem create a
utopia of quote nations sitting peaceful
under a night sky that's how good of a
mother she would be
i remember when i had similar delusions
about my own parenting skills
maybe not quite that megalomaniacal but
you know close enough
and then i realized that it's hard
enough to get my own kids to go to bed
and sleep peacefully under a night sky
much less entire nations
i still have not mastered that eight
years in how do you get kids to just go
to bed
and sleep peacefully i i haven't done it
one time i have not succeeded yet
entire nations the whole world forget
about it
now the best and most generous possible
interpretation of this poem is that anna
mccord
is sort of sweetly clueless in a naive
feminine maternalistic sort of way and
she thinks that snuggles and hugs can
solve any problem doesn't realize that a
tendency towards conflict and land
disputes and tribalism and warfare are
deeply ingrained in the human psyche
all of the snuggles in the world won't
change that
but if this was just rooted in a sort of
optimistic yet ignorant and
simple-minded misunderstanding of human
nature it would perhaps not be worthy of
the same level of mockery that it's
receiving
because it's well-intentioned you know
just really stupid
unfortunately i think the truth is not
quite so rosy for anna mccord it is as
usual
less a matter of naive innocence than of
extreme suffocating narcissism a
narcissism so immense in its severity
and scope that she not only believed she
could single-handedly cure the world of
violence and war but it's a good idea
for her to make this claim
while the world is in the midst of
violence and war
and it's for that reasons for the
narcissism that ultimately we must say
um the same thing i would say
tana mccord if i was her mother
you're canceled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
wadowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin